on est bien en deuxième semaine d'examen
du budget les sénateurs vont examiner
les dépenses de l'état des différents
ministères quelles vont être et bien les
points de modifications importants de la
majorité du Sénat on parle également du
budget de l'écologie qui va arriver bon
non on aura plusieurs on en aura sur le
plan de relance qui touche à sa fin
alors qu'on continue d'y mettre des
moyens on en aura même sur le budget de
travail avec par exemple autour de tout
ce qui est formation des milliards mal
dépensés le une réforme autour de France
compétences qui est une réforme non et
mal financée non financé alors qu'elle a
été mise en place dans le cas qu'elle a
précédent qu'elle devait apporter mille
et une réponse et puis vous évoquez le
budget d'écologie nous sommes pour une
écologie de l'efficacité de la bonne
dépense pour permettre la transition et
on va avoir l'occasion d'aborder par
exemple aujourd'hui cette espèce de
d'ineptie qui fait que lorsque l'on
encourage la conversion de des véhicules
thermiques au profit de véhicules dit
propre on favorise l'importation de
véhicules produits en dehors de l'Europe
écoutez les Français nous envoient
depuis un certain temps des messages il
faut donc accélérer permettre d'acheter
aux Français des véhicules à portée de
bourse je dirais produit en Europe et si
possible en France donc l'idée c'est
bien de renforcer ce lien de proximité
de faire que ces efforts de transition
soient utiles pour l'économie française
et pour le contribuable juste en
quelques mots ça veut dire que la
majorité du Sénat pourrait diminuer le
budget alloué à l'écologie oui bien sûr
parce que il y a une alerte à faire et
nous allons bien expliquer les
orientations mais je je j'ai
parfaitement confiance sur le message
qu'on envoie pour accélérer on a vu
tellement de gaspillage avec ma prime
rénov etc il faut entre guillemets il
faut mettre fin aux erreurs
[Musique]